a couple of weeks ago i went on a little
bit of a rant
here on the observation deck about the
kind of science fiction we deserve
um i was mad about prometheus but now
i've been thinking about
to paraphrase commissioner gordon the
kind of science fiction we need not the
kind of science fiction we deserve
i saw a movie the other day called
beasts of the southern wild and
it's sort of sci-fi it's told through
the eyes of a six-year-old girl
so it's hard to tell whether this tale
of a katrina-like storm that
floods a sort of gulf coast area maybe
in the future and releases
kind of giant beasts into the world is
just her imagination but
you know all stories are imaginary right
and if pan's labyrinth counts as fantasy
this counts as science fiction but it's
a special kind of science fiction right
it's a it's post-apocalyptic science
fiction and that's a genre i've always
loved
um even back when i was staying up after
my parents went to bed watching the kind
of
shot on the cheap in the mojave sort of
stuff the mad max knockoffs
i loved it and i will go on an adventure
in the forbidden zone chasing after
cherry 2000 android at the drop of a hat
but i'm starting to think about
post-apocalyptic sci-fi in a different
way
and i think that's because it seems a
lot more imminent stories like beasts of
the southern wild or the novel
the wind-up girl by paolo bocce galoopi
are telling stories not set in the
distant future but
to quote max headroom set 20 minutes in
the future right there are things that
could be happening right now in fact
they sort of are as i'm sitting here
shooting this colorado is
basically on fire there really was a
katrina-like storm i mean that really
happened we lost a chunk of the gulf
coast
and that is worrisome but
we don't watch science fiction about
this stuff or read science fiction about
it because we want to revel
in the end times we watch it because we
hope that science fiction
can be in some cases better at teaching
us things
than science you know
this is a little bit of embarrassing
admission but to prove my point i'll
tell you that max headroom the show that
i mentioned a minute ago
is one of the things that turned me into
a reporter it's a science fiction show
it was
good but maybe a little silly it was a
about a intrepid crusading journalist
in kind of a cyberpunk future with a
computer generated version of his id
floating around on the monitors behind
him all the time telling jokes
and i really wanted to be him i wanted
to be edison carter coming to you live
and direct for network 23.
science fiction turned me into a
different kind of person and i think he
can do that for everybody
i think that the point of predicting the
future
sometimes is so that we can change it